The way we see the world is actually quite
complex. Our eyes are not like a camera that
takes an image that we then go and process.
As we look at a scene our eye moves continuously
to different points in the scene in order
to improve its understanding of what is in
front of it. So seeing is actually a very
active process.
So researchers have developed technology that
allows us to study where a human being is
looking; involves a camera which looks at
the subject’s eyes, and perhaps an illumination
system. So with this we can work out continuously
and in real time where a human being is looking.
Now this painting was used in a very famous
study that was conducted back in 1967 into
how a human subject’s gaze depends on the
particular question that they were asked.
So what they could do is take a subject, ask
them a question and then track where their
eye looked within the painting. So here is
an example: here is one trace, one subject
trace. You can see that their gaze is moving
all around the room. So of these three questions,
which question do you think was asked that
led to this particular gaze pattern by that
human subject. I will let you think about
that for a moment.
And here is the answer. The question that
was asked is: ‘What are the material circumstances
of the family?’.
So in order to answer this question, the human
subject has directed their gaze towards the
possessions of the particular family. So they’re
checking out the furniture, they are checking
out the paintings on the wall and so on. So
given a specific question to a subject, our
eye moves over the scene in a particular way
so as to best answer the question. It’s
not just a matter of taking a picture and
processing it: our eye actively moves around
the scene in order to best answer the question.
Here is another experiment. See if you can
work out which question has been asked.
We can see that the gaze is checking out particularly
the facial regions of the particular people
here. So the question that was asked is: ‘What
are the ages of the figures in the painting?’.
So clearly it is useful to look at the faces
of the people in order to work out what their
age is.
Third one, in this particular case this is
what the subject’s gaze did. We can see
him checking out the faces, and it is also
checking out the whole body of each of the
human subjects in this painting. And the question
that was asked is: ‘What type of clothes
are the family wearing?’.
So given the subject was answering that particular
question, then their gaze is focused just
on the faces and the clothes of each of the
people. It is not looking at the furniture;
it is not looking at the paintings; it’s
not looking out the window.
It is important to understand that seeing
is a very active process. Now it is driven
by perhaps some of the fastest moving muscles
in the human body. So the human eye is able
to rotate at up to six hundred degrees per
second, and has a phenomenal acceleration,
something like 35000º per second squared,
so amazing muscles are able to point the eye
very quickly anywhere within the field of
view of the eyes.
So this lovely quote that I like very much
by a very famous early vision researcher David
Marr. And he says vision is ‘the process
of discovering from images what is present
in the world and where it is’. So vision
is a process. I think that is a very important
message to take away when we start to think
about how robots might see.